hey what's up guys my name is Samuel
Leeds I'm a property investor and this
week you're gonna learn absolutely loads
of golden nuggets and secrets about how
to start and scale a property business
starting with as little as twelve
hundred pounds I'm gonna be interviewing
Lauren and Kaylee they become
financially free they work teachers now
they've quit their job and you're gonna
know exactly how they did it you'll
enjoy this one thank you so why don't
you just give me a little bit of
background into how you guys met and why
you chose the property we've grew up
together
yes family literally since we were born
yeah our mom's went to school together
so we've known it to live a long time
yeah we always wanted to we've always
talked about businesses together oh yes
and then we've got into property we
bought our own properties early days did
well by doing the walk selling them on
making a bit of money no that's what the
very traditional very traditional just
traditional very traditional way I
rented one of mine out I sold your
soldiers were you working hard they were
you a teacher full-time teacher and you
and you only quit very recently like
three weeks ago high five oh cool
so okay so tell me about what brought
you to the crash course and how you have
changed strategy recently because I move
recently you're kind of blowing up right
now you had a better health scared I was
going dude Wow and they think it was
down to stress when I said when I came
on the crash course I had all my face
was normal and drooping I don't remember
seeing that so yeah it was a friend at
school actually it got me into you was
watching you on YouTube I looked online
the crash course was three weeks later
in Burma go bopped on hmm still went
even though I wasn't very well just come
out hospital yeah why do you think you
were so stressed out with your job was
it hard I worked in boarding school yeah
all day as a teacher and all night as a
board in-house parent looking after the
students all weekend if all my
sick yeah see I just think it's 24 hours
a day I was working I just think if
you're that stressed with a job yeah
yeah
that was what we said we said we can't
carry on halsted in it yeah home because
obviously she was working away for years
came back home when we said right you
know yeah tired of working long hours
and being so stressed at one point you
know you'd be crying having even in
panicking about going into work and I
think teaching in general is just it's
just getting too much yeah and so when
that happens to love it on the crash
course sat down with a long face
yeah is that what it took to get you I
met some really lovely people on the
class I was like I'm so sorry but I was
like dribbling on my face don't you look
pretty healthy now that point you didn't
know who's gonna return not teaching for
three weeks yeah yeah you're not working
for somebody else you're not you're not
panicking about you know doing X Y yes
making beds painting I think being been
really busy is not what you are exactly
yes and we work hard and we win yeah
yeah I'm so stressed nothing I'm never
stressed really hard cuz you doing what
you want to do you work into your values
yeah you know we have the time of day to
say right today's we're doing this I can
turn around I care it's great so okay so
that kind of really even go to the crash
course know so I'm littering I didn't
know about it and so I basically um and
she was like listen you need to watch
this you need to you need to kind of
jump on this with me just because
previously I toured on houses we
obviously knew that this was our passion
as regroup didn't we just leave after
after that I obviously when they're
coming back home we were saying right
let's do some it together now you're
back being away from home there was only
so much we could do together it was all
by myself and so yeah once she came back
and we had the knowledge from the course
and I hope she's like watch I'd be they
went to myth we went for the rents are
an option like initially from the crash
course yeah because what how was the
crash cause different to the YouTube
videos it's not remember that's not to
educator the whole thing like I should
be the young witch she was there really
wished she was there but I met some two
guys who were joint mentoring with
hopefully at the moment really nice guys
Jack and Adam so what the so that was i
sat at the back and you were said you
were at the back all of you at the back
you at the back make the least money
[Music]
good for you so after the crash course
then I know you've got one particular
deal that I'd love to talk about I do
like that's we can do like a little case
study on it which is being very
profitable why don't you just tell me
about how firstly you found that deal
and kind of like what happened and
they're making go married to the figures
a little bit yes so they from July Cass
crash course in July I was on summer
holidays so every day I got how many
times we viewed so many rent to rents
will try and look in Liverpool to begin
with rent to rents for students suit
accommodation HMOs because we drank we
can rather I was looking at buying as
well at this point we were stuck with
cash we weren't sure what to do with it
I had to buy somebody out of a property
unfortunately when you said bother make
me bribe them out of the house it was my
own or someone else's property oh why
not telling no no no no no so I got to
use the money I had to buy a certain
person okay out of our home yeah so
that's now rented out so we kind of
stock with cash weren't we slightly just
for a short period you worked so hard
for cash to do that kind of thing so we
were looking at the rent surrounds we
went we viewed properties in Liverpool
everywhere everywhere we found a really
good one in Liverpool just like well why
would I let you do it well I want to do
it and that's what we face we talked
about this at the crash caused oh yeah
in lease option same story yeah but it
doesn't matter yes they do it themselves
and then they end up making loads of
money off says this it's fine
goodwill that you've created everything
in business is gonna be about goodwill
like you came the question was free
course yeah you watch me do a free you
haven't paid me a penny no and they like
but the amount of goodwill that I've
created I know that that's what
ultimately that's that pays off and the
same with you with this with these
landlords that are like these rich
landlords in Liverpool now yeah I know
we tried on that we went to see us still
up for sale and that was back in July
but still for sale they're still for
sale yeah so it might be potential joint
venture with the guy I met on the course
he had cash I could get a mortgage so we
were trying to do that option we found
this amazing apartment right on Sefton
Park I don't have you know her in
Liverpool no beautiful area gorgeous
it's done in really expensive when down
down down the route are getting this
apartment so close to signing the deal I
was gonna buy it but he was given the
cash I was caught in the mortgage in
that all fell through so that kind of
just sentinels yeah just a bit
disappointed yeah because it was
constant and being on our summer
holidays we weren't enjoying our summer
holidays when we should have been in the
right it was kind of out on the back
burner a little bit I went back to work
September so this point no deals no
deals so you've spent your whole similar
way yeah working hard you you stressed
out when you're told to rest yeah I
supposed to be very had to rest to get
my face yeah but you're not arresting
you're working like crazy yeah and and
now you're going back to work we were
driving were me everywhere nothing to
show for it yeah yeah well I was driving
from new
where I was living yeah to Liverpool to
Runcorn to Manchester we got a bit of a
deal in Rochdale no we just because
there was three properties with
potentially 20 rooms and we just
panicked with partners whose big know
what you'll always mess up on your first
deals that was our first and we panicked
does it make sense doing it during the
starting with us morning but that could
have been bad I know I mean we can't so
then we were in fact then we were
looking at bigger properties in Runcorn
Katie's dad happened to find was a six
bedroom house we were going to look at
that and view it he went to look at it
and saw next door but one there was a
how to let mmm so we called calls call
didn't wakes we knew it was a big
property yeah we went to view it and it
was 12 bedrooms we were scared yes well
we came out and we didn't tell because
we knew we wanted as soon as we walked
out Sunday they were currently running
it has a better breakfast yeah really
profitable the show knows the profits to
show us the margins FN didn't they so we
did all the numbers I did all your
numbers at all or some panics or
slightly didn't we we went to view it
again
they were like you can do what you want
with the property you know it's rent to
rent you can the landlord's pretty nice
is he's got a lot of properties so he'll
coming over look how much did he want
you to give him guaranteed 1200 I
happened with 12 bedrooms anyone in 1200
yeah and you got the keys you litigate
on the contract yet and that property I
know is literally it this is very recent
like three we could got a case three
weeks ago so you got the keys three
weeks ago so what happened when you got
the keys mad the old managers were
moving out
yes they admit that it wasn't them that
open the property they were they were
renting off a landlord for their B&B for
seven years they were moving out the day
that labrum was moving in so you live at
the property don't you yeah they were
literally coming out of one door and I
was going in the other they were
carrying boxes I was carrying boxes in
here's and prior to them moving out
because they had
business landlines they were getting
bookings and thankfully they were
passing the bookings on tours knowing
that we were going to be the ones that
were taking it over
and so that week that they were moving
out we had about seven guests in the
first weeks we were like great business
is booming and we've not had to do much
how much profit did you make the first
week 1,300 majority of it was cash as
well we banked 700 pounds in a week and
then the rest was all car payments 1,300
pounds card payments oh you'll still get
the money yeah yeah they were paying
like debit card like we had a cartridge
seven pounds with cash yeah yeah of
course
yes we still pay tax yeah yeah yeah so
that was crazy right because we wanted
it to look nice wanted it to get off to
a good start so we were up all night
painting making it all lovely for the
guests of course so at this point were
you thinking holy moley we had a bit of
a moment yeah yeah exactly
I had one one day and you weren't one
the next day so we talked live in there
her living quarters needed a bit of work
and it still does retail doors I'm still
living out of a box and got it via text
and yeah so it's just really really busy
wasn't it
and then the second we came we were told
that we couldn't keep the landline
number so we were thinking right that
that number is all over social media
it's on TripAdvisor it is on everywhere
that anyone wants that number previous
guess and it was Collin Daly it was
constant until they moved then when they
told us we couldn't keep the number
we're like this is like gonna start
we're gonna have to start from scratch
yeah yeah we panicked
so weak - we had one guest
so going from seven the previous week
someone we were thinking oh no what
we've done yeah and we knew we were
gonna have to put the work in so we knew
we're gonna have to get the new number
obviously get it I were everywhere I
designed my own website I'm actually
pretty impressed with it no I got me all
day what's the word jubilee
bed-and-breakfast calm Jubilee
bed-and-breakfast calm where little
gusto though right yes at the moment
it's a mixture of things so it's
changing as we see things changing yeah
the prophecy will not be a bad better
breakfast yes you're gonna what you get
well let's just get to where we're at
and they moved to the future of it so
that week you were thinking oh my god
Manic Panic the week after we agreed to
sign up to Airbnb which previous people
have said don't do it it's hard you
might get you know one night booking
which isn't feasible really we did it
anyway
we said we need many people coming in
and if you can come in through air B&B
then might eventually book through walls
again and so we just have a new was an
extra website live the number had
changed yeah how many bookings and being
crazy nice well I was like look at the
phone wasn't it just kept beeping man
beeping how do you feel when you get all
those bookings coming really a bit I
mean yes you've done that yourself that
wasn't off the back of no that was this
was from scratch yeah yeah
cuz we had a good week cause it was
coming from previous yeah good number
but it'd been you know for seven years
so then it started from scratch remorse
that's not felt good thanks this is just
all so how many profit did you made last
week but presumably like well I'm just a
second week what when we were panicking
yes but were you talking eight hundred a
week 1,300 the busy week but even if
it's like five that's worst case
scenario what worst case what we've made
it can be done I think that's worth hey
sorry okay but but but that's one deal
yeah like I don't know how much you're
making teacher right so you one deal and
you've more than replaced your income
renter and deal how much down payment
did you need to get that all this up and
running
it's twelve hundred pound deposit that
was it we negotiated a lot yeah he
wanted to months up front and a deposit
yes and then we negotiated one bump on a
month free so November was free we have
no out there what about like furniture
oh it was all there so the only thing we
had a nice bed TVs Friday's every
the previous managers off the baton beat
left all that we needed to do would be
for our own it was a bit dated
yeah we've painted and spruced up with
nice cases and cushions couple of
advancing so you were in total 12 in the
pan to him to Tibet see 1,400 pound and
absolutely everything you made that back
where you made 1,300 profit in your
first week we made defense our first
month's rent for December in a week yep
and now you make in like eight nine
hundred pound wears case scenario no
website we had no number we just had a B
so all that hard work through the summer
holidays where you could have quit and
then suddenly this they'll cut up a base
closure just go in are just good teacher
look I love the students I'm just gonna
be a teacher forever never gonna be
ripped off me to single that's right
so what so off you learn them in this
process a lot a lot yeah you just can't
give up and keep looking there's always
going to be something there isn't there
since we've don't think I've heard this
on winners on a Wednesday a lot wants
the Wong Commerce we got a couple more
leads haven't we already like our
landlord has up to 90 properties in the
area
yeah so that sort of a lead that we've
now got we had randomly we had a guy
knock didn't we the open I the doorbell
rang about 8:30 for what to do open the
door and he said oh and I've been locked
out have you got a room for the night
and I said yeah of course you know talk
him up to the room I said you know made
him more welcome and he was lovely
ex-teacher had a good chat he was a
teacher for 30 years
lovely chat with him and he said oh I'm
only in the air it's my dad's died he
said that's my house across the road
there this random guy that not I was
like so I was already trying to get this
property off him which is in the
pipeline isn't it so he knocked on the
doors where you went back council really
interested it could potentially be a
five bedroom house it's right opposite
the road isn't it yeah from there
we can see it from it could be five six
bedrooms so HMO and the area is really
popular sounds great I mean and that was
just this yeah locked himself out of his
house
I know you gave you said his house to
say on a fall it's always thinking of
what could come of it isn't it yeah what
do you think about people I mean people
will watch this story some people we
really inspired and oh my gosh I want to
do the same kind of thing whatever it
takes and and and you will inspire them
but some people just won't believe it
some people just we don't believe it
right only for our Instagram pages and
updating it and you know walk it into
work and thinking make the beds no work
to process it
yeah like coming on the train just then
we had to like oh my god we'll go into
something it's on your leads like in
London this way where's this come from
since July behind school we've not had a
minute to process any of it so it
doesn't seem real to be honest right now
what what what it is really yeah the
money's in the bank the money jakela I
don't make my animal but bank bank the
bank balance doesn't lie so scary
well what would you say to someone no
that was that was maybe a teacher
stressed out and they were like oh my
gosh you know I look that sounds like a
dream but it's just a fantasy it's never
possible but you've proven just a short
amount of time what's possible was it
been five months so I think it's going
across course because I was I was very
traditional single lengths from the
crash course I've also learned to put
your R's
interest-only so it's now actually cash
flow in me money properties you've
switched over yeah so I switch now to it
interest only that's making money so
I've just I think just go on crash
course learn because people might not
know the different avenues like you say
you need money I was panicking we didn't
have money would I'd have to give my
money to something else and go on a
crash course learn and you have just
learnt just learn and go just do it why
not like if it what's the worst case not
get any better we they've got you've got
a job saying your job cuz you've got a
job yeah
go on I was we were one Gumtree day and
night and they were still working around
the clock so you can still have you
properties on the Saturday yeah just go
go and do it and like a scary it's very
scary we're both still doing a couple
days of supply we can't we just to keep
things ticking it over and the teachers
that we speak to jealous yeah when we
initially started teaching and we do
supply you were always hoping that you'd
get up and you'd always think I'm
jealous of these teachers having a
full-time job now they're jealous of us
because we don't need to be it and we
won't be hopefully soon yes soon and by
the end you're wearing a few of our
friends the MV was just doing it getting
out there and we're going into work if
you know much about spy teaching but you
don't want do any planning though assess
in stress and you'll leave and the kids
leave at 3 o'clock so you go in and you
get in page still do what we'd love to
do but the stress is not so I think if
that's the worry for teachers that
regular income mmm you know you could
still do it on the side you get heart to
him to get holidays going view book all
your properties yeah it all the
Christmas parties that very hard to okay
the thing you've both got going for you
apart from just being you know likable
good communicators driven but he's just
you see it you're so passionate you've
got like at whatever it takes like a
fire yeah we've always been my life
what what's your strongest reason for
doing this I've had a pretty tough two
years personally and by we I bought
houses and sold houses with my a certain
somebody and that just open it just open
your eyes and gives gives it I've got
that strength in me now like you know I
go by yourself I couldn't do this on my
own you to him anymore
yeah like I don't need that I don't use
money I don't really do him I don't need
I need I can do this on my own and that
give me personally then it wasn't very
well mmm-hmm so I think with the stress
of effort I've gone on we've work had
just give me that gosh poor stood in it
and I just thought that's not my life
anymore
I want I like my nice holidays I like
I'm loved to travel the world I like to
barley last summer I'm volunteered I
know and I want to be able to do that
tomorrow would I want to yeah I have to
do that in July after that August
personally it's more that for me wasn't
it just and I just had a little boy no
families two and a half and just again
time and having family time it just it's
not just not possible when you're trying
to you know do a full-time job that
takes you over those hours your work
until the middle of the night sometimes
and it's not fair and yeah and you know
we're just
I'm never gonna be rich I've been a
teacher that's what we kind of said
wasn't it without a passion for business
actually said we always wanted to to
make money but it's all natural
my our friends have humming laughs yeah
like they go you to just like Google and
plastering courses the other day add a
class to it at all we were like we're
just learn well and then Kaylee's
boyfriend was like you to crack me up
like that I do is just come up because
we're just like what's the next thing
all yeah well if we could do that we'd
save some money were doing yeah so what
do you what do you family think of the
fact that you've been so successful
recently my dad so proud yeah my dad's
hilarious though he panics well you've
got that to pay in that I know which is
why it's nice to fall back on the supply
teacher yeah you know it's it's not it's
it's always gonna be there so just by
having a couple of days just allows us
to have a little bit of secure security
if we need it then we've got it and the
amazing absolutely nothing wrong with
that
I mean what being in a job that you
don't necessarily like or at least
having masses of stress is what it's
making you well normally no ones that
I've learned a lot of people live like
that a lot of people work a job that
they hate yeah
for most of their lives yeah I love
teaching I love it I love it yeah do you
what we're doing now it's nice because
it's all about the kids and we can kids
they're all part of this property for
students so I'm gonna look after them in
my own time
do nice things together I could look
after really care for them yes give them
what they need without that stress when
people think financial freedom initially
a lot of people think oh you know lying
to be like we're not close to that
probably never will be because because
you said because I won't know I worked
really hard the thing is working hard is
fun when you're doing something that you
enjoy and when you're serving a purpose
and you're helping people and you're
adding value it's fun
we're not created to lie on a beach I
don't think we're creates a lot about
forever but what you know people in jobs
that hate their job think I'd love to
lie on a beach forever you actually give
it to we yes and you'll be saying I want
to learn to be a plasterer now and I
want to get my hands dirty and I want to
go and make some chaos and yeah you know
with this deal this juiciest hack the
money that you've put down you've
already made back you've already Lisbon
let's say in a year's time and market
shifts and you start strippin your dad's
right
well you've gained yeah yeah well I
think that happen I think that property
is gonna be so it's gonna continue but
we had a really good day on Monday
didn't we we had a lady come from study
links and her role is to place
international students into
accommodation during holidays Oh like
half terms or if they get suspended or
you know they're in some emergency
crisis at school than they need to be
taken out of the school so she came and
absolutely loved us absolutely loved the
property she was singing our praises
apparently in the office yeah so
hopefully that's a good Avenue
we've just well yeah we've just kind of
got the go-ahead from them so you know
that could be potentially really really
good for us couldn't yes I think the
biggest thing that you've got going for
you is just the courage and the
craziness to be able to just step out
because it is possible making money in
property being a property investor
property entrepreneur rent to enter no
money down deals or very little bit down
as they are possible but we I didn't
think it was did you know
I'm very traditional and bought a house
save the money doing it open I sold it
on rented one out you know so you know
so your proper background in the
property you had one or two properties
you almost had to unlearn yes because
and we're programmed you know the way we
brought up which is work hard save money
put it in the bank and that's very like
that right but it's not since and the
reason we're programmed to do that is
because what it just keeps your slaves
right so what when did when did the when
did the penny drop I mean was it at the
crash course or was it like if so what
what point do you think you know what I
don't need to work hard
definitely but at what point do you
remember because you were sat at the
back to begin with not a bit skeptical
we both get to go yeah where's gets all
the very conscious I had a weird face
going on or do - it's like way better
than what you're doing the same thing
you're gonna keep getting the non-face
yeah probably about lunchtime off the
first day of the crossbows really and
then what you just felt because I wasn't
kind of needed money and I'm really into
buying somebody out yeah I'm stock right
and it was the rent to rents that got me
really on the crash course for yeah but
the people that say you can't do this as
a to do they're always broke yeah anyway
serious like yeah well my thought was
what have I got to lose about the
toughest two years of my life yeah you
said to me didn't act in yeah Lauren
nothing is worse than what you've been
through yeah and you okay that's me
don't know you're whenever yes yeah like
nothing you have gotten you said to me
they were dating you just look at you
know look at you know it's why it so
good so I think it's just thinking
nothing what can I lose yeah go to knock
on someone's door say that's what I do
can you rent to man we're not bothered
now by and you like last night you said
just go knock on his door
we've done that many and we've got so
many knows it's like okay yeah
terrified the conversation your uncle's
just really promising conversations you
know what this you could have very
easily said you know when you did six
weeks you've got lots of nose you go
deal you could have very easily quit and
then gone I went to the crash course I
gave it my all and it didn't work and
then you would have been wondering the
beauty you'd become one of the online
trolls now sometimes you do need to
pursue there a little bit I think and we
I think what I've been through being a
teacher yeah and I mean it is like you
see me do the financial freedom
challenges in a week and I think
sometimes people think oh well if I go
for a week I'll do it and what the
forget is I've been doing this for 12
years you know so it's possible to do it
in the week but realistically if you set
aside a few months or even a year
I said denied by just a year so from
July - July for the crash course or the
next July I wanted to give myself so I
don't thinking I'd leave my job next
summer and it happened let happen to six
weeks yes I went back in at that time
we're gonna fall I can't do this I
thought there's something's gonna happen
again
yeah I want to be ill again I just
couldn't do it so then we went again for
it didn't really like we need to do it
and although whilst it's risky in a
sense everything is risky and if what
the people say you know I admit risky
well do stay in your job risky because
the risk is that you're just gonna end
up 67 and broke retiring on 40% of what
you couldn't live on in the first place
for two years working forty hours a week
to get there Congrats I was working at
80 hours a week and but the other
problem with me I had accommodation at a
school because I lived in the house
mourning house so I was leaving a job on
home I don't know what to live was like
stressful living my spare rooms fine
come on we can do this and I was
literally gonna leave work without the
deal to live just take like a
one-bedroom section so talk to me about
networking because you ladies a great
networking I know in the crash course
you've got some potential joint ventures
now going on on staff
how do you how do you how do you pause
deals like that and how do you how do
you get people to want to do business
with you just showing them how
passionate you see your vision as well I
think if someone can see where you go
with what you're trying to do with your
time and your money they want to invest
more so they can see well hard-working
we are that we're not going to just mess
about mmm we're doing this you're the
real do did a 10 percent Prost I think
we see something we're gonna go and get
it yeah
we don't mess about what what made you
apply for winners Wednesday you put I
would never have done it to be honest
but you put a post about on Instagram
saying who's done a good deal today I'm
weed your sign just that dad did for the
1200 property and I just commented I
said I've just signed I'm so happy
like yeah quit my job and there's
someone called me like one of the team
yeah that's called be proactive baby the
net well I was only you said who's done
some good deals today and our site right
that's me but I have to I'll actually
you celebrating lunch and I when it came
up I went when I when I team called you
and invited you to come to me I was so
excited yeah and I think coming on that
comedy videos as well and we send our
whatsapp just put two links of winners i
wednesday in your videos and then you
you put a video up recently about what's
your next step
yeah you I said well I don't just do
that deal I'm always thinking and I said
okay what this is I was down there we
were painting them so in January what's
the deal then we're gonna get speaking
best is it look at what properties yeah
and we're not even finished doing what
would you want to try to achieve now
knowing that you're thinking of the next
thing what the plan then like
strategy-wise games 2020 we've got a
couple of esters are willing to well
with with hoping we've got about 40 K to
play about with we just don't know
whether to buy a property and flip it or
I'd like the I like that do and we
finance it buying reefer a bit pulled
them on y'all
yes and then Eva sell that property or
rent it we're not sure so you're just
you gonna go are you gonna get more into
rent deals so you're gonna go you're
gonna get more internet deals create
cash flow then raise finance use that
cash flow to build wealth that way we
can lose the supply and just those
little side jobs yeah
nice the rent the rent will do that well
yeah the immense immense we'll do that
and then the back the money were getting
invested what we ferb next yeah this
amazing other than a wage it won't give
us a wage yeah so what what one piece of
advice would you give to someone
watching this inspired and wants to go
and do it you've got nothing to lose
someone said to know someone shuts the
door in your face
Joe I'm fat landlord it was really rude
to was in Sector Park really rude no
problem
that was the worst that's the worst
that's gonna happen don't be
disheartened by it because there's
always somebody else waiting for the
deal don't be scared and the guy who not
good the day he's come from matific
country because he's about to deal with
you know the loss of his parents and
he's left with a house which potentially
he doesn't need the stress of dealing
with that does he so hopefully we might
have chat with him
it could go one way don't know then
we're gonna find out probably by today
yeah it might have another five bedroom
a troll by this evening
yeah well just do it just there's
nothing to lose like that but it's not
yeah I love that nothing to lose and in
a job you get a secure income yeah if
you're going on a few doors mm-hmm and
they say no yeah you've still got a nice
income I think what I have a few no able
to get that kind of backbone do yeah I
think if we went back to that first
house in Liverpool where we went I'll
just do it myself and did it now it'd be
a different story
why cuz that was our first one yeah it
was we couldn't speak to it who trying
to read off the spiel and it doesn't
work oh you get the deal now yeah you
probably would get the deal now
be confident you probably messed up I
mean we must have done something a
little bit wrong yeah we were nerves but
there's more ladies now absolutely
smashing it in this industry well you
say last call the winners of Windows
well women like in women now yeah I'm
one of those it used to just no it's no
it's me one and now we have the whole
work winners Wednesday community so now
you because you're on the winners show
we're gonna have a dinner with you every
six months we're a closed Facebook
community we've got a whole bunch of
stuff because I because my attitude is
when people take one move and they go
out and then get some success and then
they come on and they put himself out
there on the show they're gonna a lots
gonna come back that way
you know you're building your brand but
then I want to make a move who's been
the best winners Wednesday episode that
you've seen so far I like the mom and
daughter they when they pulled that
house apart and they knocked all the
walls down yeah yes yeah they would did
it for me
I'd dinner with them just the other day
they were kind of my turning point from
because I watched were they around
September time probably they must have
been because that was when we were like
oh yeah I watch that before they
inspired you and they picked you back up
but now in the same way it's probably
going to be thousands of people that are
feeling love yeah that's the case
they'll watch you and then they'll come
on the show in six twelve months
anything anybody had a B&B before then
what how'd it be in big to do anything
so we said we'll turn bedroom 3 into the
small single room this is the bamboo
yeah okay no wait are you gonna be back
yeah yeah it's like separate combination
so you've got like three houses well yes
so not only are you making 13 in Japan
profit but you also live in rent for a
yes oh my goodness that is fun
they were saying I had no job and
nowhere to live and then got a 12 button
property answer was live in Victorian
building must show you some pictures so
we've gone into it 50/50 immediately and
my job is just to care and manage it
with her see how busy we get and just be
forbidden to design and that's what my
little niche comes into this we're
talking about the kids saying about the
kitchen so that's one of the bedrooms is
becoming a kitchen so the rooms can be
hate you know my bedroom so my personal
bedroom needs plastering yeah horrendous
penance Ron Allen's plastics come on get
back
seven people ridiculous quotes and then
oh yeah I'll do it believe and then
difficult we went to college didn't we
went to Sciences course
well now it's possible it's like a three
week three week past record we were like
let's do it I went on a plaster in crash
course great master what was going no
it's too hard you will not be able to do
it there's like twelve fourteen it's
like Victorian so that all only is
renovating still exact that's how I
figure that's my new like mantra in line
you go when you get you've been through
the worst I could probably ever go for
yeah I think after the valleys comes the
mountaintops I'm finally getting over
that when it what's your favorite
winters Wednesday I like where the two
girls you had are my sisters they do
yeah so it's had to me don't they
mmm as the Emma and Kate a recent one
that yeah and they were basically had
properties at Manchester oh yes you'll
meet them soon yeah
they had yeah but they're just doing
single like always feels yeah they do
like single service
or when we are doing to the winners
when's their Facebook group your webcam
is I'm really excited to see your next
steps to helping you support in there
well Congrats
good job hey guys thank you so much for
watching that I hope you inspired I hope
you go on to take massive action and
become the successful if you do become
successful in property as a result of my
training all the videos please do apply
to be on Windows on a Wednesday
that's the www winners on a Wednesday
calm I'll leave a link below in the
description also if you want to watch
more episodes like this there's a
fantastic interview I did with two
ladies again in Manchester completely
financially free through rental rents
and you can check that interview out
right here also if you want to come and
learn the skills yourself and you want
to call them the property investors
crash course completely free you can do
that over here and don't forget of
course to subscribe to the channel over
here thank you so much I'll see you